wouldn't that be why the are we
even getting taxed on crypto anyway okay
I can understand admit you have it cool
or or there should be like an exit tax
all right you cany you can sell into
stable coins but the moment you sense
your bank account okay that's fair game
tax there we don't have these
laws instead they're stifling in
Innovation the best crypto companies on
this planet are all moving out
like you can't start a crypto
company as an American it's it's like
it's basically illegal unless
you have a ton of well they're going to
just come after you you can start it
they'll let you go for a while right and
then they're going to be like and you're
done